chuckling maracas TT is a renowned human
rights activist and genocide survivor
she was born in Rwanda and was only nine
years old when she lost her parents and
six siblings to the 1994 genocide she
was inspired to share her story of
survival and hope for the first time in
2001 since then maraca TT has delivered
hundreds of lectures on genocide
prevention and human rights
she's also addressed the UN General
Assembly and regularly participates in
human rights conferences Muraki today is
the founder and president of the
genocide survivors foundation which
educates people about the crime of
genocide and raises funds to support
survivors greetings
I'd like to begin by saying how honored
I am to participate in this critically
important symposium and I would like to
thank Rob Rehman Evelyn Ryman and the
entire team are the Nexus Institutes for
having invited me to participate in this
timely a much needed discussion as you
heard in my introduction my name is
Jaclyn America today and I am one of the
survivors of the 1994 genocide against
Tutsis in Rwanda this is a genocide that
began in April of 1994 and lasted for
approximately 100 days and in those 100
days it is estimated that over a million
people were murdered
so how did that happen how is it that
Wanda became an environment where
neighbors killed neighbors where
teachers killed their students where
priests and nuns participated in the
killing of their fellow church members
and in the case of ethnic intermarriages
where people killed even their family
members to begin I always emphasize that
it's important to always remember the
genocide as a crime is not something
that happens overnight genocide as we
have seen time and time again is a
step-by-step process like the Holocaust
and other genocides which preceded it
the 1994 genocide in Rwanda did not
arise in a vacuum Hutus who are the
majority is in a group in rwanda did not
just get up one day and want to murder
their Tutsi neighbors the genocide was a
step-by-step process the pre genocide
Wanda had a number of what I would like
to call risk factors which created an
environment for the genocide to happen
and I'd like to begin by talking about
some of those risk factors that led to
the genocide firstly when I was born in
Wanda in 1984 I was born in a country
which had an ethnic based ID system this
meant that when you're born in Wanda you
are labeled either Hutu Tutsi or twelve
those being the three ethnic groups in
Wanda the ethnic based identification
system was introduced in Wanda by the
Belgians when they Colin
Rwanda as an effort to divide the
Rwandan population because as we know
the theory of colonialism was that of
dividing in order to conquer
unfortunately for us when rwanda became
independent from Belgium in 1962 the
Hutu led government which took power
chose to continue this same ethnic based
ID system which the Hutu government used
to monopolize power and to discriminate
Tutsis in every aspect of the Rwandan
society so growing up in Wanda I knew
that I lived in a country where my
ethnic group Tutsis did not have the
same basic rights as Hutus did not have
the same privileges secondly the pre
genocide Wanda was also an environment
where anti Tutsi propaganda flourished
the who to lead government had this
narrative of Tutsis being foreigners
being invaders who had come from
Ethiopia and other parts of East Africa
and had oppressed Hutus during the
monarchy system so at the very early age
who to children were taught that Tutsis
were natural London's like themselves
but they were foreigners and they did
not deserve the same rights and
privileges as Hutus thirdly the pre
genocide Wanda was a country which had a
culture of impunity so while the 1994
genocide is a largest killing of Tutsis
in Rwanda and it is only widely known in
Western
trees it was not the first killing of
Tutsis Tutsi massacres took place in
Rwanda in 1959 and throughout 60s and
70s and whenever the who led government
ordered these massacres the massacres
went unpunished so before the 1994
genocide Rwanda was an environment where
Hutus had come to believe that it was
okay to kill Tutsis that in fact it was
their civic duty to kill Tutsis whenever
the government ordered it finally and in
continuing to show that the 1994
genocide in Rwanda was not an event that
happened all the sudden it's important
to talk about the intensification of the
dehumanization campaign which preceded
the genocide in October 1990 a civil war
began in Wanda between the then Hutu
extremists government which was
controlling Rwanda and the Rwandan
Patriotic Front which was an army made
up mostly of Tutsi exiles who had been
forced out of Rwanda as a result of the
previous Tutsi massacres that I
mentioned but the RPF or the wanderin
Patriotic Front was also made up of Hutu
moderates who also opposed to the Hutu
extremists government and when this
Evora began in 1990 life of Tutsis like
my family in Wanda became increasingly
worse Tutsis were portrayed in Wanda's
widely read newspapers and on the radio
as spies as cockroaches as
and as a thickness which needed to be
gotten rid of by the time the genocide
began in 1994 who'd to civilians in
Wanda understood that they are Tutsi
neighbors were an enemy which they
needed to get rid of I'm giving all this
background again to emphasize that
really by the time the genocide began in
April 1994 the physical and mental
preparations for the genocide have been
taking place years before and the risk
for an impending genocide were very
clear and if the international community
had the political will to prevent the
genocide there is no doubt that this
genocide could have been prevented but
unfortunately as we know the
international community failed to act
despite the ample warning of an
impending genocide and because of all
the physical and the mental preparation
for the genocide when the actual
killings began they were very efficient
when April 6 1994 when the extremists
who led government called on Hutu
civilians to kill the enemy namely the
Tutsis Hutu civilians in masses picked
up machetes and clubs and other barbaric
instrument and went from door to door
killing Tutsis men women and children
indiscriminately when the genocide began
life for us as Tutsis in Rwanda became a
living nightmare I was 9 at the time and
I always say that prior to the beginning
of the genocide while I was away
of all the discriminatory measures
against my Athena group while I was
aware of all the in justices that had
been committed against my effing group I
always said that I was nevertheless a
happy child I had led a relatively happy
childhood I had my parents I had four
brothers and two sisters so I was born
in a very large family I had many aunts
uncles cousins friends unlike any other
9e old child I had goals and dreams and
I did not think that something such as
that which occurred in Wanda in 1994
would take place and that my dreams and
my goals will be brought to such a
tragic end but in the days that followed
the beginning of the genocide myself and
all Tutsis in Rwanda found ourselves in
an environment where each day when we
survived we did not know whether we're
going to leave to see the next day
during the genocide I was exposed to
horrors that no child or really anybody
sure ever have to experience or be
exposed to today 26 years after the
genocide I'm so haunted by the memories
of when I used to watch as Tutsi men
women and children were being murdered
around me in knowing that any time I
also could be killed I am haunted by the
memories of when I used to watch
children whose arms and legs had been
hacked off and I'm haunted by the
memories of the nights when I used to
listen to Tutsi toddlers and babies
cry for parents who they will never see
again during the genocide like all
survivors I came face-to-face with death
many times and each time I thought that
that will be my last day on earth but I
survived initially due to a Hutu family
who hid me my grandmother and a cousin
in his home and after were discovered I
later found a refuge in an Italian
priest owned orphanage which had existed
in Rwanda prior to the genocide and this
two Italian priests had made the
decision to stay in one done during the
genocide at the risk of their own lives
in an effort to try and save children
like myself who are being hunted simply
because of our ethnicity because of a
Tutsi ethnicity and it is in our
orphanage to myself and many other
children survived by in the aftermath of
the genocide I would discover that why I
have been one of the survivors I will
learn that neither my parents nor my
four brothers or two sisters had
survived I will never forget the day
that I learned the one day during the
genocide my Hutu neighbors people whose
children I grew up playing with and
going to school with and going to church
with these Hutu neighbors had found my
parents and all my siblings in their
hiding places and had taken them to a
nearby river where they proceeded to
murder them one by one
and to throw their bodies in that same
River their bodies never to be found
never to be buried never to have a
proper tumblestone my grandmother's my
uncle's many of my aunts and cousins
suffered a similar fate some of them
were burned alive others were beaten to
death
others were buried alive and many of
them were buried in mass graves after
the genocide as you can imagine it was
very difficult for me to understand what
had occurred in Wanda how it is that one
day I was a child with family and that I
had found myself in an environment where
I was being hunted and where my family
had been murdered simply because of
their ethnicity I was one of the lucky
genocide orphans in that I had an uncle
who had left Rwanda fears before and was
at the time living in the United States
and after learning that I had survived
and that my parents and siblings had
been killed my uncle decided to adopt me
and to bring me to the United States so
in 1995 a year after the genocide
I found myself coming to this country
way I began learning English and trying
to start a new life for a long time
after arriving in the United States I
was haunted by the nightmares of what I
had witnessed I had no desire to talk
about my experience because I myself was
so struggling to understand
what had happened in Rwanda and it
wasn't it was not until 2001 at the age
of 16 when I had the honor of meeting a
Holocaust survivor by the name of David
Kurtzman who came to my high school
class and spoke to us about his
experience as a child during the
Holocaust and it was David who
ultimately inspired me and motivated me
to start sharing my story of survival in
2001 and for many years after that David
and I traveled all over the United
States in many other countries sharing
our experiences his during the Holocaust
and mine during the 1994 genocide
against the Tutsis in Rwanda we spoke
and Luke went I continue to speak to
audiences young and old and I speak not
because I enjoy having to repeat the
horrors that I witnessed in 1994 or to
have to revisit the loss that I suffered
in one day 1994 but I speak today and I
do the work that I do today through my
nonprofit organization genocide
survivors foundation because I strongly
believe the stories of genocide our
stories which need to be told today even
more than ever it is said that those who
don't learn from history abound repeated
and unfortunately this has been true
when it comes to the crime of genocide
we never again promise which was uttered
after the Holocaust is still yet to
become a reality today we still live in
a world where there is often too much
silence and indifference
in the face of genocide and other mass
atrocity crimes and until that silence
and that indifference ends until we
recognize the protecting human life or
human life from the crime of genocide
which is the worst crime that human
beings can commit until we realize that
it is all in our national interest in
humanity's interest to prevent this
crime then unfortunately it's going to
continue to happen as history has shown
us dear friends as we all know today we
are facing a pandemic the corona virus
or kovat 19 and emic the current kovat
19 pandemic has affected all of us as we
all struggle with the anxiety and the
pain that it has caused but if there is
one thing that the Cova 19 pandemic has
reminded us of it is our
interconnectedness our common humanity
our common destiny as human beings as we
have seen the Cova 19 virus does not
distinguish between race religion
nationality or or ethnicity people all
over the world are dying and suffering
as a result of this pandemic and as we
continue to do our part to save lives
and to engage no necessary social
distancing I would like us all to be
mindful of other viruses that plague our
world today and they also take lives
every day racism anti-semitism
xenophobia hate
these are also viruses that claim lives
every day and like covert 19 virus this
virus also do not know any racial
religious nationality or ethnic borders
or differences these are viruses which
when they go unchecked and unaddressed
can lead to nothing less than genocide
as we have seen time and time again
prevention then entails a renewed
commitment to fight all forms of bigotry
and extremism as many of us know today
we live in a world where many religious
and ethnic minorities live under the
constant fear of persecution or even
worse extermination as many of us know
we live in a world where even places of
worship are no longer safe some
hate-motivated violence as we have seen
in recent times therefore as we continue
to borrow the current kovat 19 pandemic
i want us to also be reminded of the
urgent need to take both personal and
collective responsibility to move toward
a world where all human beings can live
free from fear of persecution or murder
simply because of who they are or
because of what they believe learning
from our genocidal past
fighting the current rise of extremism
in all its forms working tirelessly to
prevent future genocides this I believe
is the best way that we can honor the
millions of men women and children who
have lost their lives to the crime of
genocide I thank you very much for your
attention
you